[Music]
this is the story of the United States
public culture it's a story of many
partners it's a story of hostile like
this one in your audience and this one
in Norfolk Virginia it's a story of the
leprosarium in Carville Louisiana a
hospital for study and treatment of drug
addiction in Lexington Kentucky the
National Institutes of Health in
Bethesda Maryland and the clinical
Center there it's a story of quarantine
stations at our major ports of entry
like this one at Miami and this one at
New Orleans as a matter of fact the
story of the Public Health Service can
be found in many places throughout the
United States and its territory
the story began with President John
Adams in 1798 when he signed the act
establishing the marine hospital service
or honor of the Public Health Service
today many people have helped establish
the services distinguished traditions
people like Joseph Goldberger who
pioneered in studies of pellagra a once
widespread dietary disease Leslie
lumsden whose work in typhoid
epidemiology and rural sanitation is a
cornerstone of modern public health
practice Joseph mountain who stimulated
nationwide interest in many fields of
Public Health practice and
administration such as chronic disease
control and the health problems of the
aging Charles Armstrong who is
adaptation of poliomyelitis to rodents
speeded up polio research and Edward
Francis whose studies of the origin and
causes of tularemia have done much to
improve our knowledge of this disease
other Public Health Service scientists
developed vaccines against Rocky
Mountain spotted fever and typhus and
perfected many others the service was
also instrumental in the virtual
eradication of malaria in the United
States today the Public Health Service
employs over 21,000 people in about 250
occupational specialties
these include physician nurses sanitary
engineers that is scientists dietician
veterinarian physical therapists
pharmacists social workers
administrative specialists instrument
makers animal caretakers nursing
assistants clerical personnel and a host
of other specialists necessary to the
effective operation of the service civil
service personnel comprise the largest
number of these employees about
one-fifth of the services employees are
regular and reserve officers of the
commissioned Corps a long-established
career organization of professional
medical and health personnel and one of
the uniformed services of our country
because of the professional nature of
the services activities many of its
major programs are directed by
commissioned officers officers of the
commissioned Corps serve either in the
regular Corps or career service or in
the reserve corps on active or inactive
duty officers on in active duty belong
to a component of the reserve Corps
known as the commissioned reserve the
commissioned reserve is a readily
available personnel held in reserve for
grave national emergencies and trained
to meet critical situations affecting
the health and well-being of large
numbers of people such emergencies might
involve the destruction of our city's
extensive illness and death from disease
epidemics while the unusual health
problems associated with major natural
disasters
the Public Health Service is the oldest
and largest of the five operating
agencies that comprise the United States
Department of Health Education and
Welfare the Public Health Service is
organized to work closely with state and
national organizations through national
conferences and advisory groups of
private citizens to give meaning and
direction to its many programs the
actual work of the service is carried on
by four major Bureau one of these
bureaus is the office of the sir
in general this is not an operating
Bureau but is responsible for
coordinating activities and providing
administrative services for the three
other Bureau the three other bureaus
known as operating bureaus are the
bureau of medical services the Bureau of
state services and the National
Institutes of Health
let's examine these bureaus and their
activities one at a time first the
bureau of medical services this Bureau
operates foreign quarantine programs it
administers grants for construction of
hospitals and medical facilities
operates numerous hospitals and
outpatient clinics have the Indian
Health Program it conducts Dettol and
nursing studies of personality and makes
professional personnel available upon
request to other federal agencies
personnel in the Bureau of medical
services work in Public Health Service
hospitals from Massachusetts to
California and in outpatient clinics
providing medical care to seamen of the
United States Merchant Marine the United
States Coast Guard and the families of
Coast Guard officers and enlisted
personnel they serve in public health
service hospitals and clinics on Indian
reservations in the United States and
Alaska in federal prisons with the Coast
Guard in Alaska and with the Coast Guard
on the high seas personnel from the
Bureau of medical services are also
assigned to quarantine duty with United
States embassies in foreign countries in
this country quarantine personnel are on
duty at our major seaports and at our
international airports where they
determine the health status of
passengers entering the United States
from abroad and keep daily surveillance
for disease bearing insects that may
find their way into this country the
bureau of medical services is also
responsible for the hospital
construction program under which the
federal government matches state and
local funds for the construction of
hospitals and other medical facilities
in communities where there are no such
facilities or
where existing facilities are inadequate
Public Health practice the control of
disease in the community as a whole is
the responsibility of the second major
operating Bureau the Bureau of state
services through research demonstration
training and consultation a personnel of
this Bureau work closely with state and
local health agencies on many different
health problems the bureau coordinates
the activities of regional staffs
located in eight of the nine regional
headquarters of the Department of Health
Education and Welfare it is through
these regional staffs that many of the
public health services cooperative
federal-state and interstate programs
reach the people of this country the
bureau of state services assist state
and community health officials on such
problems as mosquito and fly control
animal borne diseases safety of public
water supplies Water Pollution Control
standards of Sanitation governing the
preparation and serving of food and milk
personnel of the Bureau of State
Services study develop and demonstrate
methods of community refuse disposal
they train local health personnel in
effective methods of sewage treatment in
rodent control and in housing hygiene
they study the relationship between air
quality and community health and conduct
research to improve the working
environment of the industrial worker
they also work on Indian reservations to
eliminate health problems caused by in
sanitary conditions the Bureau of State
Services provides grants to States to
help them finance health programs such
as the establishment of new County and
local health services in addition there
are grants to States for specific health
problems these include the Buerkle osis
diabetes heart disease venereal disease
cancer and dental decay
rats are also made to support studies of
the special problems of the older
citizens in our communities specially
trained epidemic intelligence officers
of the Bureau of state services provide
disaster aid to states in the form of
prompt investigation of disease
outbreaks another unit of this Bureau
the National Office of Vital Statistics
compiles analyzes and publishes national
reports on births deaths and disease
outbreaks to augment its field
activities and the research programs of
the service the Bureau of State Services
operates the communicable disease Center
in Atlanta Georgia the Robert a tab
sanitary engineering Center in
Cincinnati Ohio and the Arctic Health
Research Center in Anchorage Alaska the
global scope of the bureau's activities
is indicated by its international health
programs in approximately 60 foreign
countries where the service provides
technical assistance in the development
of health services here are some nurses
in Iran this is a physician in Formosa
and this is a sanitary engineer in Iraq
the third major operating Bureau in the
Public Health Service is the National
Institutes of Health in Bethesda
Maryland this Bureau referred to for
brevity as NIH consists of seven
research institutes the clinical center
and four independent division although
the service conducts research programs
in many places NIH is the largest
installation for this type of work in
modern well-equipped laboratories NIH
scientists are making important progress
in many areas of research in areas such
as heart disease cancer mental illness
arthritis and the metabolic disorders
the neurological and sensory disorders
allergies and infectious diseases and
diseases of the mouth and teeth at the
clinical center the findings of the
laboratory site
it is and the experience of the
physician are brought together in a
concentrated attack on disease to
accelerate man's knowledge of some of
our most stubborn disease problems NIH
scientists also work at the Public
Health Services Rocky Mountain
laboratory in Hamilton Montana where
they study diseases that are
transmissible from animals to man NIH
has also the responsibility of
certifying the safety purity and potency
of biologics used in the treatment of
disease over two-thirds of all the funds
appropriated to the National Institutes
of Health by the Congress are awarded to
scientists in the nation's medical
schools universities and other research
centers these federal funds are helping
to expand medical research and research
training throughout the country as a
result our knowledge of the major
diseases of man is rapidly increasing
bringing us closer to the day when the
main causes of disability and early
death can be reduced to a minimum one
type of award granted by NIH helps
medical schools expand their training
facilities such as laboratories and
classrooms which permit modern methods
of instruction another type of award is
the research fellowship which helps
talented young scientists and her
research careers still other funds are
granted to nonprofit institutions for
the construction of essential research
facilities in many parts of the country
now let's look once again but briefly at
the organization of the Public Health
Service it is part of the United States
Department of Health Education and
Welfare under the direction of the
Surgeon General the service administers
programs in three major areas of
activity these are research of the
causes of disease the prevention of
disease and promotion of health and the
care and treatment of patients who look
to us for this kind of service through
its 21,000 employees the Public Health
Service today brings benefits to every
American not so much as a direct
dispenser of services but as a leader
and guiding influence the services work
is reflected in an increasing store of
professional information
in popular knowledge of medical
developments in improved local health
programs throughout the United States
and its territories the Public Health
Service as it has for more than 150
years is dedicating its energies and
resources to increasing man's knowledge
of the falls prevention treatment and
control of diseases that the people of
this region and their children are more
adequately protected than ever before
from the suffering and hardships
produced by disease
[Music]